depuis des années j'en ai comme un
chiffonnier de la banlieue du caire
son but essayer d'améliorer l'émission
de nouveaux 48 personnes dans ces
bidonvilles obligé il rejetait pas c'est
cela et que les conférences gens qui est
récoltée a déjà permis de construire une
maternité un dispensaire et une école
dans l'industrie bidonvilles son projet
actuel la construction d'une usine de
transformation des déchets en engrais
jean de compost a comme but de sauver
des centaines d'enfants qui meurent à
cause du tétanos de transformer ces
immondices en compost pour fertiliser le
désert d'egypte qui avance puisqu'il n'y
a plus le limon du nil et troisièmement
grâce aux bénéfices de créer pour les
chiffonniers des ateliers mais voyez
vous cette usine de composants va être
une preuve qu'il ya de la solidarité de
la fraternité et de la justice dans le
monde
quel est le message que vous venez
apporter à ses élèves et à toutes les
personnes que vous rencontrez au cours
de vos tournées et bien tout simplement
c'est un appel à la justice c'est à dire
la justice et le partage pour moi voyez
vous je ne fais pas appel à la charité
je demande aux hommes de vivre en
solidarité
c'est à dire de se pencher sur tous ceux
qui n'ont pas autant pour partager en
commençant par vieillir sa propre ville
son propre pays évidemment en s'étendant
aussi au tiers-monde dont je fais partie
serait manuel parcourt le monde peut
faire partager son idée de la justice et
pour sensibiliser le public en
particulier les jeunes à son action j'ai
trouvé donc mon avis il a fait beaucoup
de choses pour ces gens qui
qui funky et aides en plus total ils
étaient déshérités c'est très important
quand nous tiennent au courant de ces
choses parce qu'on n'entend pas beaucoup
parler finalement et je trouve que c'est
un témoignage très intéressant parce que
l as tu nous parler avec des mots facile
je veux dire on a pu comprendre
facilement les problèmes
s'extrayant